we got the Muzak so we're up in Edmonton
for a seminar conference I think what
are you what is the workshop workshop
yes for four-story hive tell us has
brought us up to you brought us up to
Edmonton for a day-long workshop there's
the agenda with the national screens -
we're gonna learn about working with the
CRTC actually the specifics of dealing
with the grant money yep
and also some mentorship advice about
actual other production and whatnot so
it's looking like and giant tubes oh and
we got we got these tubes huge we got
these giant story hi Brandon Dux yeah
there you go
I also have a tiny tiny head but so so
looking forward to that it's gonna be
gonna be a good day yeah so I hear this
was worth mentioning we're at the mix
and mingle part of things and all the
snacks
it's a movie concession because we're
filmmakers so okay so that was a that
was a great day that wasn't amazing that
was an amazing day it was a lot of fun
meeting a bunch of other people doing
doing story high projects a bunch of
other Calgarians a bunch of Advent
onehans you know doing doing their
projects and I think it's it's really
cool a lot of cool people a lot of great
instruction yes the best part about I
think
we were assigned a mentor and that's
basically someone
very well-established into the film
industry in subway or for and Dan and I
were basically assigned to Joe Novak who
is
a very very well respected and
well connect so connected producers more
than a producer but he does a lot of
things
so having him basically he's just like
yeah here's my cellphone number here's
my email phony email me whatever you
need if you find yourself backed against
a corner or you want some help with
something I'm here which is kind of a
like super grant relief
he's already kind of given
tips on how we should approach riding on
location because we're still kind of
waiting on it that's partly my fault got
really sick this week
that will not happen starting tomorrow
but it's also good to have someone on
your side
oh man we we spent a lot of time today
going over the various
a lot of the specifics so it was it was
stuff that I already had access to
because I've got the I have the
deliverables package like their
expectations on behalf of Telus but then
they went through them all again twice
in but in a lot more in the more sort of
conversational detail because the way
that I've got it is the giant document
that was written by lawyers and I read
it all it's it's like you know it's dry
it's page after page after page of the
stuff and even though I understand it
it's the difference between
understanding and internalizing is huge
so it was a lot easier to internalize
when you've got someone standing up
there at the front being like okay like
here's here's this here's that also I
mean I've been like nah I guess not so
much the deliverable stuff because I'm
used to reading deliverable packages
like hey we want you know here's what
here's the codec that we voids and
here's your gains the technical staff
via is all had to me and but like oh
well here's here's sort of our schedule
of expectations and you know and stuff
like that and it was I think the part
that was really great was really them
sort of reminding us that like this
really is intended to be a growing
opportunity a learning opportunity that
it is probably the lowest stakes money
you will ever get it's it's about
completion and it's about sort of you
know it is about trying to produce the
best thing that you can but then within
that like you know you're not gonna if
if if things go wrong if you if you fail
to like you know if it just kind of
turns out bad if things don't come
together it's not like you're you know
financially liable you're not gonna get
sued by your investors so it's like you
know that kind of low stakes opportunity
to experiment particularly since we are
doing something that is a lot kind of
more out there having that lower stakes
is great it's a great opportunity
there's a really good day
there's always the fear of not reaching
your attention
you're always kind of afraid of I have
this idea it's in my brain
how do I translate that out into the
world in a form in which people want to
watch great and sometimes that's a
really big roadblock
you want to do it right I think that's
the one thing that Dan and I are really
trying to grasp right now is we both
have the passion and the commitment to
get this done we just but I want to do
it right and I really want to do it well
and that's those a huge fuel for me but
it's also one of the biggest hindrance
me too
not overstressed but it's putting a lot
of pressure on myself
wanting to do
yeah
so I think I think that's it like we go
in to go into the dry specifics but I
think that's that's good it was a great
day and it was really rewarding a lot of
fun and we've still got two hours of
driving to do to get home so on a
beautiful beautiful the qe2 headed to
the Calgary just just three hours of
pretty much this we might we might wave
to one side or the other
but but dear that's the one thing I
really
wasn't over
we can no my my my our emitter doesn't
go far enough to see anything out the
side
yeah
all right we'll leave it at that take
care